[Music]
what is one big excuse that you could
take on right now today and do something
do something about and if you started
there what would your life look like in
30 days what would it look like a year
from today what would it look like five
years from day if we took on some of our
bigger excuses can you imagine what
would happen inside you know even just
New York alone if he had 1% of the
population that took on their biggest
excuse without like the creative
generative effect of that what that
would bring
frankly our brain is hardwired to
survival and because of that our brain
with any fear that we have or any
justification that we make as to why we
do something or not do something I
believe it comes a lot of those answers
come back to survival and you know
there's usually a positive intention
behind some of the excuses that we go
and make you know maybe even
preservation of our own energy or
preservation of self there's a lot of a
lot of times like fears are good
rational fears and there's a good
intention behind them
it's just uncovering that and seeing you
know kind of unpacking it and what
what's really going on there I think for
starters I think some of the excuses I
may come to mind in terms of common
excuses I don't have enough time I'm too
busy I you know I've got too much on my
plate I I'm too old and too young and I
don't have enough money or you know like
too too much money or if I know if
that's really an excuse but there's
there's a million you know I'm not good
enough I you know it's just I think it's
really actually the more created excuses
the ones that are a little bit more
sneaky and situates that like the ones
where we can convince ourselves that
they're good reasons so a lot of times
if I don't want to compete in something
or I feel like I'm not going to win or
whatever I've got some type of fear of
failure that I'll make a really creative
excuse we make thousands of
justifications I think probably a week
if there's there's like excuses to me
a mountain with no there's no end to the
trail there's no summit to it we're
never going to arrive at a point where
we're completely free of our excuses but
I think the idea is just to have a
little bit more awareness around some of
the bigger ones I think that it starts
with looking at telling the truth to
yourself about something right I believe
that the extent to which you can tell
the truth to yourself about whatever
excuses you're making is the extent to
which you can be free from it it's you
have to to start there you know I love
the spirit of the message of for
instance like saying something like
anything is possible but I don't
actually believe it it's anything is you
know maybe possible in the future but at
this moment in time I'm not going to go
and benchpress 10,000 pounds right at
this moment in time we aren't going to
go and colonize Mars and you know so
we've got these like bigger society-wide
use excuses that we make as human beings
you got individual smaller excuses that
we make is you know just as people
living our day-to-day lives but I would
say to for people watching this the
worst thing that could happen is that
someone frankly we're saying from my
perspective at least if someone watches
this and starts beating themselves up
over the excuses that they go and make
if people go and say to me after a
speech is done like wow you've done some
awesome things with your life but I suck
and I can't do anything then I kind of
miss a point like I want people to know
that I am a master excuse banker and I
know just now how many excuses I go and
truly make and I have to go and like
tell the truth to myself about the
excuses that I'm making now kind of this
idea and I didn't come up with it it was
Alfred Korzybski in 1931 said that the
map is not the territory we all walk
around with our own mental maps based on
our experiences maps of the world and we
like to go and think of those maps as
reality instead of realizing they're
just freaking maps and they're just you
know up here and in some maps are better
than others a good map you can navigate
accurately with a bad map not so much
and we all have our own map
you know really I would start with by
telling the truth to yourself
[Music]